le ballet de Mauricette texte Dédé
d'Almeida illustration Jacques Luder
Orphie édition
Morissette a cassé son balai sans le
faire exprès un balai qui est dans la
famille depuis 100 ans qui a appartenu à
Mémé Rosalie à Tata Jacqueline et à
cousine Pélagie quel malheur en plus la
fête des sorcières a lieu demain à
minuit aucune sorcière n'a le droit d'y
aller sans son balai pauvre Morissette
que vas-tu faire
et si je le collai avec de la colle
forte et si je l'enduisais de bave de
crapaud
ultra gluante et si je le clouais à
l'aide de clous ensorcelés et si je lui
disais abracadaba répare toi mais rien
ne marche le balai est toujours cassé
bon Guy Morissette je sais ce qu'il me
reste à faire elle prend son balai sous
le bras et sort de chez elle dehors elle
rencontre Mélusine son ami où vas-tu
Mauricette lui demande Mélusine je vais
au bois maudit rendre visite à euse bien
la ténébreuse quoi s'exclame Mélusine
mais tu es tombé sur la tête tu sais que
tu risques de ne jamais revenir je sais
mais j'ai un gros problème à résoudre
avant de ma minuit et seules et bien
peut m'aider
il n'y a pas un instant à perdre
Mauricette court vers le bois maudit
cette forêt remplie de monstres où il
fait toujours nuit elle frissonne parce
qu'elle a peur et froid
on raconte de six effroyables choses sur
eux et bien la ténébreuse on dit qu'elle
a dans sa bouche trois langues fourchues
de vipères on dit qu'elle a 5 yeux 3
devant et deux derrière car cachés dans
ses cheveux on dit que lorsqu'elle a
très faim elle dévore tout cru qui
compte s'approche d'elle après avoir
répondu un petit peu de sel sur sa tête
Morissette avance en claquant des dents
soudain une maison surgit devant elle
est-ce la maison d'oser bien la
ténébreuse
cette maison ne ressemble pas du tout à
une maison de sorcière
sur à grosses goutte Maurice sept sonne
la porte grince et s'ouvre bonsoir dit
une voix douce je suis
osez bien Mauricette manque de tomber à
la renverse qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette sorcière elle n'a pas cinq yeux
elle n'a pas trois langues de vipères
elle n'a même pas une petite verrue de
rien du tout sur le nez c'est vrai dit
osez bien j'aime les belles robes de
dentelle et les Falbala j'aime aussi
recevoir des visites mais personne ne
vient jamais jusqu'ici tu es la première
sorcière que je vois depuis des lustres
que puis-je pour toi mon ballet cassé
pouvez-vous le réparer rien de plus
simple dit aux et bien ferme les yeux et
sans respirer répète après moi
abracadabra scoubidou bidou poil au bras
et rien du tout
Mauricette obéit abracadabra scoubidou
bidou poil au bras et rien du tout
dit-elle les yeux fermés sans respirer
quand elle rouvre les yeux son balai et
tout beau et tout-pimpant
oh merci c'est crimoricette merci et au
revoir il faut que je me dépêche d'aller
me préparer pour la fête des sorcières
il est minuit passé la fête bat son
plein il y a à manger des petits fours
aux œufs de lézard et un somptueux
gâteau aux champignons noirs Morissette
fait un discours mes amis notre fête est
très réussie mais il manque une sorcière
c'est eux c'est bien la ténébreuse elle
a réparé mon balai et si nous allions
terminer la fête chez elle ce n'est pas
possible répondent les autres sorcières
elle est bien trop effrayante tout le
monde a peur d'elle depuis toujours nos
mamans avaient peur d'elle nos
grands-mères avaient peur d'elle et même
nos arrières grand-mères avaient peur
d'elle faites-moi confiance
Maurice 7 suivez-moi une extraordinaire
troupe de sorcières ne tarda pas à
traverser le bois maudit de mémoire de
sorcière on avait jamais vu ça les
sorcières trouvèrent eux etaient bien
époustouflante et bourrissante
ahurissant tout ensemble elle dansèrent
des polka endiablé jusqu'au petit matin
ezebia ne s'ennuya plus jamais toute
seule au fond du bois maudit Morissette
vient la voir presque tous les jours et
les autres sorcières veulent toutes
avoir des robes comme elle